hey hey everybody it's jeff from cackle
hatchery i wanted to talk a little bit
about some tips today when you get your
baby chicks from cackle hatchery uh they
arrive in boxes kind of like this or
they might be bigger
our main topic today though is making
sure you get your baby chicks off to a
good start
there's a big difference between
hatching out baby chicks at home under a
hen
or an incubator versus getting mail
order checks okay
chicks that have hatched at a hatchery
or the chicks that go to feed stores uh
you know they've been through two days
of of transit so they have lost some
body mass they've been stressed and they
require a lot lot more heat on arrival
than let's say you're taking some chicks
out of your incubator okay so there's a
big difference on how you want to start
your baby chicks out
when you're getting a mail order uh baby
chicks through the mail so
we
say that you have to have in order to
have success
you need a brooder reflector lamp
something like this one it's got a guard
that you take off and put on it so if it
ever happens to drop it won't start a
fire
these are relatively cheap you pick
these up anywhere
we really recommend to have a
a red bulb you can have a light
uh bulb if you want to but these will
put out the uh and warm the air around
the chicks not only
warm the chicks but warm the air around
the check
we usually recommend 125 watt for every
25 chicks and then of course they got to
have a lot of room to get away from the
heat
but you want about a hundred 105 degrees
at the floor level
for the baby chicks so uh when they
arrive
their body temperature is
is low and they don't have it in them to
raise their body temperature up so their
normal temperature is around 104
so you've got to figure out and
artificially
warm their bodies up to that temperature
so they'll start getting active starting
to eat and drink so that's real
important so
may order chicks require a lot more heat
than if you're taking chicks out of your
brooder or out from underneath your hen
if you have a gqf these are really good
brooders too for mail order chicks
it has a heating element in here that
heats up really hot
and uh it's got a thermostat on it
and so you know if all your chicks are
huddled right here
they're too cold
if the chicks are kind of sleeping
around this area they're just right if
all your chicks are way up to the front
of the brooder
then it's too hot and you need to lower
the temperature so as your chicks grow
they're going to take less and less
temperature
now
after
five
generally more like seven to ten days
you want to try to figure out a heat
source that does not produce a light
okay so we want to get your chicks off
of having 24 7 light so
this is where these come in handy
uh after seven to ten days uh
you know you could install one of these
for the chicks
i've got several different brands here
there's other brands i'm not trying to
leave out any other brands it's just
that these heat plates do not heat the
air
and they're a lower temperature
and they don't produce a light so that's
good later on but you cannot use these
on arrival for baby chicks
i mean i'm you you can have
success but you've gotten really lucky
if you have in the past so
these are more for chicks after uh
you know like i said seven to ten days
for mail order chicks if you've got an
incubator at home and you're hatching
your chicks out
you can probably have success with these
uh but we got one brand here there's
another
brand
basically again it's a heat plate that
does not produce
a heat source that heats the air
so but there's several different brands
here
so the theme of this short video is
for mail or chicks we're not talking
about when you're hatching at home we're
talking about when you are ordering
chicks through the mail day old baby
chicks
you cannot start them off with a heat
plate like these okay
they have to have
you know a good heat source that's gonna
heat the air around them
and uh
so
that's uh
the theme of this uh
video and we thank you for listening
this is jeff at cackle hatchery hope you
have a blessed week